dites moi philippe quand j'étais plus
jeune et que je regardais samedi soir à
la télévision
j'avais un rêve c'est d'être un jour
assis à côté de vous sur un canapé et
que vous m'interviewer ces gav tepa chez
chapier là je sais que vous le reprenez
votre bouquin la phrase de art book
balle qui dit que finalement quand un
journaliste intervieweuse journalistes
c'est un peu comme danser avec sa soeur
je sais mais posez moi quand même deux
trois questions
quand vous avez en face de vous jeune
femme très belle parce qu en lui posant
des questions sur son métier sur sa
famille pensait à autre chose
jamais jamais jamais jamais jamais
arrivé vous ça vous arrive et vos venant
je suis comme vous un menteur
et à je voudrais savoir si vous
connaissez vous vous préoccupez de
connaître les réponses aux questions que
vous allez poser
oui nationale quand je pose une question
je connais la réponse donc vous savez
quand on vous dit pas la vérité
voilà les joies lente fodié ça aussi je
faisais ça aussi alors quand vous êtes
ses dires et d'antenne 2 par jean michel
gaillard et philippe guillôme le même le
même jour que vous à ce moment là vous
allez j'ai rien déclaré je suis une
seule à avoir rien dit vous avez déclaré
c'est une bande de zozos j'ai pour
éviter de leur faire de la peine qu'il
était viré eux on savait qu'ils feraient
rien d'autre de leur vie fallait pas
trop méchant avec le dit matt monte ou
baisse en ce moment étant donné l'heure
il ya déjà pas mal de gens qui vont se
coucher
j'ai même l'impression que les gens qui
nous regardent sont moins habillée qu'au
début de notre conversation